it's been three months since the Apple
watch four has hit store shelves and we
can now finally take electrocardiograms
with it let's go through how to set it
all up and see what it's got to say
about my heart first off you want to
make sure you're updated to iOS 12 point
one point one on your iPhone and then
head to your watch app go to general
then software update and you should see
watch it was five point one point two
available for download go ahead and
download it also remember that you'll
need to place your Apple watch on the
charger to install the update after it's
all done simply open the ECG app on your
Apple watch it then asks you to go to
your health app to set it up as you're
going through the setup it'll remind you
that it can't detect heart attacks or
strokes and then ask you to take your
first ECG before taking the ECG on your
Apple watch make sure it's snug against
your wrist and that both your arms are
resting on either your lap or a table
otherwise you may get an inconsistent
reading then simply hold one finger flat
against the crown for thirty seconds as
it performs the electrocardiogram you
can even use your thumb for a
potentially more accurate reading
luckily for me it didn't detect any
atrial fibrillation and gave a sinus
rhythm result this basically means that
the upper and lower chambers of my heart
are beating in sync however the results
can vary between recordings so make sure
to run multiple tests on different days
to make sure you're in the clear the
Apple watch also gives you the option of
adding in your symptoms if you're not
feeling well all of this will then be
recorded into the help app where you can
track all your results and even export
PDFs to bring to your doctor going back
to the watch app on your iPhone you can
go to the heart settings and adjust the
heart rate that you would like to
receive high heart rate in low heart
rate notifications you can also set up a
regular rhythm notifications as well
this will make your Apple watch
occasionally look at your heartbeat when
you're resting to check for a regular
rhythm now if you do receive a
notification you should definitely see
your doctor because the Apple watch
confirms a theb with multiple readings
now let's say someone from your family
wants to run an ECG how can you do so
without messing up your personal health
records in your iPhone well first of all
it may not be accurate since the test
may be based on your age and health
information but if you do let your
friends try it you can go to the health
app select an ECG result and go to the
bottom of the page to delete the
recording so it doesn't mess with your
health records so we know that atrial
fibrillation can lead to heart attack or
stroke but how common is it well the CDC
says that
only 2% of people younger than age 65
have afib while about 9% of people 65
and older have it so if you're still
pretty young you most likely don't have
it there's a good chance that most of
that 2% is close to 65 years of age
anyway so most likely running ECGs on
your Apple watch will be something you
do just for fun but if you are that one
rare case it could save your life now I
can't see very many people 65 years of
age or older wearing an Apple watch
unless someone in their family bought it
for them for the sole reason of checking
on their heart and for the new fall
detection feature that can automatically
contact emergency services in that case
the Apple watch series 4 is a great
device for them alongside the new ECG
feature watch it was five point one
point to finally bring some new
complications to the infograph watch
face including male maps messages find
my friends home news phone and remote
thanks for watching guys and make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
more videos like this one